[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're going to
hear in one evening
the clarinet played by
many different people
in many different ways.
We're hearing it
in a jazz setting.
We're hearing it in
an orchestral setting.
And I think that gave a nice
opportunity for the audience
to experience the full
breadth of this instrument.
[MUSIC - INI OGUNTOLA,
"CASCADES"]
Third grade is the
earliest age you
could join the band program.
And so every year they
would show the beginning
third graders-- they'd
have a presentation, where
the fourth and fifth graders,
they would go and play
their instruments on
stage to the third graders
in the audience.
And then it was trying to
convince them to join the band
and to pick an instrument.
And so I kind of wanted
to play saxophone
because of a little bit
of my dad's influence.
That was his
favorite instrument.
But the clarinet
was a lot smaller.
And then I realized that it
could fit in my backpack,
and I wouldn't have to lug
around the heavier saxophone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
I saw this concert advertised.
Then I saw if you bring your own
instrument, you can play along.
And three--
[CLARINETS PLAYING]
The fact that we're
inviting clarinetist
from around town to come
and actually play with us,
that's kind of unprecedented.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've been learning new notes
throughout the rehearsals.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The rhythm to this
piece changes so often
that it's really fun to play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To be able to play with
these great clarinetists,
that's just once in a lifetime.
[CLARINET SOLO]